vai vai veloce e successo nella tutti
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo video sono
pa vj ci sono super meat boy l'episodio
3 che si stanno portando sempre via la
mia tipa ovviamente ascolta fratello
tratto sono più grosso della strada
spiegatemi come perché quando comunque
ragazzi laghi la fabbrica e non l'avevo
notato guarda ragazzi fino adesso sono
uscito a fare per lamentare lo schifo
sono riuscito a fare premente tutti sono
riuscito a fare un cazzo precisa fare
veramente tutti dire che cazz in ogni
episodio se riuscito a finire un set di
livello ogni volta non so come non
chiedetemi però si apre è la prima è
andata
non so se in questo riuscirò a fare
altrettanto ragazzi ma ci proviamo ci
proviamo ogni volta ma questa sarebbe
sale cosa c'è al sale di così strano da
non poter essere marco toccato spiegato
niente sono un deficiente
non è così facile come sam porca [ __ ]
ho preso una supposta nel culo senza
volerlo se si ok ok amen amen
adesso riesce tutto il suo sangue vabbè
non voglio scoprirlo regala una roba
tipo che sempre col maestro ma questo è
ovvio
l'ho fatta io io io io mi sto chiedendo
come mai non avrò risposta si continua a
farmi questa domanda cioè essere
innamorato così tanto di una tipa tanto
da poter perdere tutto questo sangue
io non farei queste robe ma neanche se
la tipa fosse pamela anderson eppure 8
facendo promesso di carne che bei
ragazzi tra tutti il range game co fatto
da cat mario arruolabile guy questo
diciamo che il più che il più merda bye
bye bye bye device e se sì toto godo è
una cross si vede che sto godendo si
perfetto
sono caduto nel centrato il buco che non
lo centro mai vorrei che la tragedia
dell'anno io non so veramente come cazzo
gestiva il suo gioco tranne che così che
culo avevo fatto una roba che non so
neanch'io come ma perché cadono il buco
perché c'è un buco di merda ma perché
devo cadere nel buco come se non ci
fosse un domani che ama perché no no no
dai a parte gli scherzi non è possibile
ok lo scriva non so neanche io che ho
schivato la che non chiedete no cazzo
che nervi perché perché me ne frega un
cazzo de l'ultimo le lascio lì finché
non di madonna quando figlio questa roba
certo è comunque a parte sta roba io non
ce la posso fare libro di collegati ci
sia a figo devo lanciarmi manco fossi
uno shuttle che figo che questo non era
difficile però non ancora finito magari
devo stare zitto orche calmi calmi
ok ci arrivò grazie ha detto ci sono io
guardo se non ci arrivavo potevo
incazzarmi che la metà balzata a parte
il toto bello anche su questo mi piace
dovrei riuscire abbastanza facilmente
poi non lo so ma ok ok bravo no sì bravo
signor brown o canto non è difficile non
è di film si può fare ma perchè non vai
a destra ok ok ok e io l'ho premuto
questo qual è il problema guardaroba
cioè non hanno senso lo premolo fremaux
sopprimendo il dove cazzo va ma vai a
destra gesù perché poi sembra che sono
io deficiente ma vi sono anche
deficiente però
se con questo gioco è strano io non lo
so perché mi dà questa sensazione di
strano astra il pane bianco e grosso al
vento si bravissimo ad onna che salto
dove vado cazzola ok zaccardo non solo
non sapevo neanche dove stesse andando
va bene lo stai facendo è la madonna e
vabbè cazzo chiamate terminator la
prossima volta che ne so se ci sono
entrato il casinò come di giocare a chi
va a pro perfetto senza ad ridendo
scherzando ce la stiamo facendo e vabbè
che bordello bordello ok ok entra
bravissimo ci voleva tanto allora adesso
non detto no si ha meno fermato prima
oh mio dio 50 decimi di secondo prima
meraviglioso non chiedetemi come ho
fatto non ne ho la piu pallida supposta
di merda ma che cazzo ne faccio sta
andando discretamente bene nel senso che
la madonna tra l'altro ragazzi come lo
ha fatto senza morire ma anche una volta
cioè non vorrei viene totalmente
concentrato non me ne so la marca
accordo perfetto e questo è impossibile
come cazzo faccio per stare a galla in
possiamo che hai detto perfetto perfetto
vai vai vai vai vai vai vai vai
[Musica]
cos'è successo me
[Applauso]
[Musica]
io veramente sono parole così se
clicchiamo più di così facciamo anche il
sugo non vorrei dire sì sì sì sì ok ok
ok ok cosa sto facendo incredibile
ragazzi è diventato un platform nel
summer fantastico bene comunque non è
male no grandi regali grandi e gran
giocata oggi e dove cazzo vai gran
giocata nel senso che gli sto facendo in
tempo per poter finire tutti i livelli
nello stesso video quindi non è una cosa
che non ci avrei mai sperato e ve lo
dico a caso dove dovrei andare
qualcuno ha delle spie ok ma cazzo
ditelo che ne so io per l'amor di dio è
niente ho provato ma il suicidio era
inevitabile ci ha aspettato due ore
vorrei vedere
ok ok capivo perché non c'è un rigido a
posso fare così cazzo vai vai veloce e
ci posso mai credere ma che cazzo come
perdonatemi la capra la pazzia di prima
veramente non riusciva a concepire sta
roba è una roba
ok sì ma cygan pesca in assoluto credo
sia altri incasinato di tutti
una donna che casino ai vai vai veloce
in buco madonna il caso schivato no no
no no no no no no avevo fatto una roba
che non mi riusciva mai più di tutta la
vita non so neanche io come ho fatto a
farla come ho fatto io ci credo e lo su
per il culo tutto quello che trova ok ok
ok ok ce l'ha fatta fatemi fatemi vedere
le morti di questo vi prego marche
bordello mica sono morto 300 volte rover
sono molti modi che veramente non mi so
spiegare nemmeno io veramente ragazzi
oggi non ho parole per tutto perché è
indecente cani ok ok a dovrà esistere va
beh la madonna fa in fretta però cazzo
sì sì sì ok ho fatta non so come va bene
così treni 19 ragazzi quant'è che sono
20 fa ancora che spara michiara un
chilometro sono non l'avevo visto porca
merda
che culo che culo vi facciamo 12 ore per
fare il suo livello ma almeno ce l'ho
fatta questo caso manca perché non c'è e
straziante ricerca madonna cosa faccio
lo so non so che devo fare sono tornato
indietro ma come cazzo vaio è così ma è
così mai così va così a [ __ ] affetto
ok la chiave bravissimo cazzo ci mette
vabbè vabbè un cazzo se ce l'ho fatta
noi che ti dico va bene borsa lord
browne perfetto ciardi eva 20 st
sodomizzando ti ha già il suo prato
quante volte quello che c'è al sorriso
soddisfatto di dover quella legge il
giornale non si fa i cazzi suoi perfetto
tira lo sciacquone ovvio cosa sta
succedendo lega le tubature ragazzi è un
basilisco
cosa cazzo è bloccato nei tubi giorno
dovrebbe essere sta roba un cattivo me
brown dovrebbe anche nel senso che è
marrone proprio perché ci ha pagato
sopra capito ed i nostri a triste regalo
a cazzo succede la tipa lasciata lì
tanto bene ma devo batterlo fantastico
no bellissimo molto veloce rossi c'è
grossi c'è non ama [ __ ] controllo
michele ha messo i peperoncini nel culo
a sto tizio è impossibile race veloce
veloce veloce veloce veloce io sto
seguendo i suoi movimenti e regalo che
sono col cazzo
ok togliti cazzo avessi avuto la yama la
velocità in culo tav rimessa ma [ __ ]
cuore perché poi è marrone perché
dovrebbe essere più veloce dimesso
perché marrone o no no no no ero prima
ho fatto che lo primo dai dai su
bye bye bye bye hanno superato perfetto
vai così ma è così bello chiedo adesso
non so dove andare per ok ma come che ha
centrato ma [ __ ] dai ma dai lui ha
centrato subito il buco ed è marrone
marroni centrano il buco reja meat boy
sei la vergogna fattelo dire sì ma
perché non centra il buco ragazzi ma
[ __ ] day
sì sì ci ho fatto allora sei stronzo e
vai vai vai vai vai vai sì sì già fatta
ho vinto io ho vinto io kick ass ha
vinto se io ho vinto io fucà su che me
ne frega niente morire perché lui è
molto più magnanimo di mesi e marron
merda chi è a quello stronzo a veri che
non è allora mio nemico pensavo fosse
mini micro pronto allora siamo amici
lanciarglielo addosso lancia glielo
acciaio che tante merda niente brutto
bastardo ti ammazzo la famiglia come hai
usato uccidere il mio amico solo perché
è marrone razzista voi lo stronzo che lo
fai iniziato fuori il telecomando ma
cosa fa pensavo facesse chissà che cosa
bene sono andate giù
però ok che cosa facciamo come prossimo
livello
l'inferno è la madonna quindi ragazzi
sono caduto anche io insieme a brownie
brown i sì è una storia triste ma
possiamo ancora farcela promessa che
ragazzi è stato un video prestano
directions fuori dal mondo ma va bene
niente ragazzi concluso più episodio mi
piace se anche voi siete dispiaciuti per
browning ma sapete che in fondo in fondo
anche se marrone ha un cuore d'oro d'oro
tendente al merda e attiverà le
procedure dei ragazzi se il video è
piaciuto la solita certo momento mi
piace anche a facili facebook e comuni
di dotata edizione sono stati discreti
ma non posso belle ragazze